[Musique]
paulette guinchard künzler membres du ps
eu de michel rocard entre au conseil
municipal de besançon en 1983 comme
adjointe à l'environnement de robert
schwint maire socialiste d'alors
puis elle est chargée lors du mandat
suivant de l'intercommunalité et de ce
qui deviendra le grand besançon
elle siège au conseil municipal durant
25 ans autre mandat celui de conseillère
régionale de franche comté qu'elle
occupe de 1986 à 1997 date de sa
démission
1997 ces deux tournants de sa carrière
politique au nom de la parité
hommes-femmes le parti socialiste lui
réserve la deuxième circonscription du
doubs détenues par la droite est réputée
ingagnable par la gauche
à la surprise générale y compris dans
son propre camp
elle remporte ce siège de député je
crois que le vrai travail du député de
genre était de tout homme politique
responsable actuellement c'est de
prendre encore plus de temps pour
écouter les gens entendre leurs
difficultés
en sorte via que tout remonte à
l'assemblée nationale ancienne
infirmière psychiatrique ayant
accompagné son père très diminués les
cinq dernières années de sa vie
elle consacre une grande partie de son
action politique aux personnes âgées
en 1999 le premier ministre lionel
jospin lui confie une mission sur la
perte d'autonomie
dans son rapport vieillir en france
paulette guinchard propose 43 mesures
l'une d'entre elle devient l'apa
l'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
destiné aux personnes âgées dépendantes
puis en 2001 fait rare en politique
celle qui a été à l'initiative d'une loi
est chargée de son application
elle devient secrétaire d'état aux
personnes âgées dans le gouvernement de
lionel jospin
les gens ont peur de la vieillesse ne
voit pas que c'est un temps de la vie
qui peut être un temps très bon
j'aimerais j'aimerais vraiment
particulier autour de 6 ces deux actions
à faire en sorte que les personnes âgées
dépendantes les personnes âgées en perte
d'autonomie puissent être accompagnés
la deuxième c'est qu'on montre le temps
d'avis et un temps qui peut être un
temps de la vie très beau très différent
des autres mais aussi très doux en 2002
lionel jospin premier ministre ici en
visite à besançon pour le bicentenaire
de la naissance de victor hugo n'est pas
élu président de la république aux
législatives suivantes tous les députés
de gauche sont battus en franche-comté
tous excepté paulette guinchard
elle effectue son second mandat dans
l'opposition en 2007
épuisée par trente ans de vie politique
est malade elle renonce à se présenter à
nouveau à l'assemblée nationale dans une
émission sur notre antenne pour
illustrer sa façon de faire de la
politique
elle a choisi cette citation de marivaux
bien écoutez c'est presque répondre
[Musique]